[Musik]
hallo ihr herz maximilian aflenzer bin
lacht meister bin seit 2009 10 beim
österreichischen bundesheer versehen
derzeit mein dienst im abwehrzentrum
entdecker
zugkommandant in der muk gruppe die die
fähigkeit unser system mammut näher
vorstellen wozu brauchen wir das
überhaupt mehr können im fall in
strahlend in bevern entseuchung dem
zufall entgiften ja wir können mit dem
fahrzeug von oben von der seite und von
unten dekontaminieren zum fahrzeug das
ist einmal ein acht mal acht mit 41
tonnen maximalgewicht mit einer länge
von knapp 11 meter das ist das modul 1
für waffen geräte wir haben zwei
wassertanks mit 750 liter sprich gesamt
1500 liter wir können damit fahrzeuge
von unten von der seite und von oben
dekontaminieren
platzes
dokumente der vorreinigung
standards für die bundesliga
damit auch der gruppe direkt vom
fahrzeug geholte vertretungen in den
radkästen vom reifen während der ersten
fünf steine rom bereitet auch ganz
normal c strahlrohr stadt befassen was
sie zusätzlich weitere station der 5c
kombination es ist das fahrzeug gerade
in die auffangwanne gefahren daher
zuerst eine untersuchung durchgeführt
worden
der dsc worden dann präzise das fahrzeug
in der wanne mit uns ein besser perfekt
für die dekontamination von oben und von
der seite mit einem kran colonia in
diesem fall und aquakulturen
dekontaminieren und unterseite ganz
normal mit der landseite
zivilsenat ökologie und versichert dass
die dekontamination ein voller erfolg
war und den folgen kamera ab das
fahrzeug abmessen deinen arm ist
modul 2 das herzstück das system armut
damit können wir sensible messgerät
dekontaminieren wie zum beispiel handys
tablets oder laptops das modul 2 besteht
aus zwei arten übernahmen die bergung
kam und als dampf kamen hintergrund
sieht man kann den befund wagen mit
schutzanzug mittel
die zweite ko die hilfen hinein schieben
die tür geschlossen und der maschinist
stellt das programm je nach art der
kontamination
mengen an die wand ist das programm b
die zeit ist beträgt ca 30 minuten
uns bei der vakuumkammer da können wir
sensibles geräten wie zum beispiel ein
tablet videos oder in welche landkarten
oder in der elektronischen gegenstände
dekontaminieren mit feuchtigkeit gefegt
werden oder sich auflösen führen in
einzelteile
vor der vorgang dauert rund 30 minuten
und danach sind die schutzanzüge den
schuttmassen die waffendepots wieder
einsatzbereiten mit wichtigen daten
nicht
modul 3 ist das grenze der drei module
vom system mammut ist für die personen
dekontamination wir können zwei personen
gleichzeitig damit duschen kann man
integrierten wassertank und an diesem
tag und seien damit an unabhängig von
irgendwelchen wasserquellen oder
zusätzliche energiequellen sowie viele
befinden uns beim modul 3 am parkplatz
die leute kommen jetzt aus dem gefecht
haben sie irgendwo kontaminiert die
warten am sammeln so lange bis sie von
uns das go bekommen dann kommen sie her
wir haben nur mehr den hellen die
schutzmaske den schutz und zog die waffe
und ein magazin mit munition mit
stationen einsatz der entlade platz die
leute kommen daher mit ihrer waffe wird
einmal entladen das eben ein steckplatz
kein schießunfall passiert dass die
leute nicht unabsichtlich das eigene
personal gefährden zur nächsten station
ist abgabe war verwüstung hinter mir
stehen zwei gefäße wo die leute die
waffe den helm und das magazin ab 7
so jetzt haben wir bei der station
eingelangt schutz und zug ausziehen
hinter mir zwar deko gehilfen die den
kameraden jetzt aus dem schutz und
zugleich herausschneiden und ihm dann
auf seinem filter an filter schutz geben
dass er sich nicht selbst kontaminiert
war darunter der seine uniform an
[Musik]
angelangt bei der letzten station vor
dem vorzelt abgabe schule kontamination
der kamerad geht vorsätzlich auf die
bank und wird dann das seinen schuhen
herausgeschnitten bzw ausgezogen und
kann dann einfach mit sorgten in das
vorzelt gehen
die personen die jetzt sind es vor zeit
gegangen sind geben als erstes ihre
wertgegenstände ab wir werden dort
wasserdicht verpackt danach geben sie
ihre bekleidung ab also das oberteil des
socken und unterhosen danach nächste
station zwischen zählt und zählt findet
sich die station abgabe schutzmaske dort
wird die schutzmaske abgenommen und der
person geht nackt und das buch plattform
in dem zelt hinter mir befindet sich die
naz tv plattform wo 40 personen pro
stunde dekontaminiert werden können nach
dem waschen oder dekontamination können
die leute oder werden die leute mit
einem messgerät abgespielt ob sie nur
kontamination auf den körper haben wenn
keine vorhanden ist können die laien
ganz normal mit einer 1 wegbegleitung
anziehen tragen sich in der evidenz
liste und werden ihn dann hat man schon
verbracht dort wir uns neu eingekleidet
von dem drucken körper so wir haben
jetzt einen kleinen einblick in die
arbeitswelt zeigen dürfen die waffen
durch welche mehr sehen wenn sie mehr
interesse daran hat dann meldet euch
unten bei der angegebenen telefonnummer
oder e-mail-adresse und dann sehen wir
uns hoffentlich bald
[Musik]